rakh we're huge fans thank you so much
we've been fine since you had hair oh
thank you hey it's a choice damn good
one to see guys Rock [ __ ] [ __ ]
yeah we're wrestlers as well actually
we're actually didn't tryouts today oh
cool what advice would you give us if if
we want to win over the crowd went over
the crowd what are your names again my
name it doesn't matter what your names
are you walk around here interrupting
the rock you like you haven't seen the
Sun in 20 years you like you just
stepped out of Oliver Twist
please sir may I have some more advice
you want some advice here sir oxen
biceps your mouth what you want what you
want I'm on what the rock wants the rock
wants you to go out there take no
prisoners have no regrets have no fear
lay it all out on the line because if
you don't do that the rock is gonna find
your friend Mary Poppins he's gonna take
her umbrella yeah he's gonna shine it up
real nice he's gonna turn that sumbitch
sideways and stick it straight up your
candy asses
there's your advice straight out up
there to brownie beating pie-eating
trailblazing I'm not raising
entertaining the glove never hotter
chuck it into rejects from Harry Potter
so that's how you win over the crowd
fighting with my family coming soon
you